aquí tenemos una foto de carlos linneo
que era un caballero sueco que vivió en
el siglo 18 y este de aquí el cual es
conocido como el padre de la taxonomía
moderna y la palabra taxonomía déjeme
notar la razón
mira si las separas en sus raíces
originales tendrías la ciencia de la
clasificación de las cosas pero cuando
la gente habla de taxonomía en
particular en el caso de carlos linneo
hablan de la clasificación de los seres
vivos entonces la taxonomía estudia la
clasificación la clase
y acá
acción de los seres vivos o de los
organismos voy a ponerle así organismos
bien y bueno antes de que surgían las
ideas de carlos linneo las personas se
daban cuenta de que había especies de
animales que los leones tienen ciertas
características que los hacen leones y
que se pueden cruzar entre ellos y cosas
así que los monos o los chimpancés se
pueden cruzar solamente entre ellos lo
que los hace especies distintas y que
los osos polares son especies separadas
y los humanos también son una especie
separada pero su verdadera innovación y
lo que él puso sobre la mesa es que
propuso agrupar a los animales no solo
en especies sino también agrupar a las
especies en otras categorías y justo así
es como obtuvimos el género si agrupamos
especies similares estas forman un
género pero esta idea también data desde
los antiguos griegos entonces él fue
todavía más allá dijo por qué no agrupar
los géneros similares y así formar
órdenes y por qué no agrupar las órdenes
similares en clases y por qué no agrupar
las clases similares en reinos
entonces lo que él hizo fue decir a lo
mejor puedo crear un árbol de la vida
puedo crear una estructura donde podamos
ver qué tan apartados están dos
organismos y es por eso que él es el
padre de la taxonomía moderna ahora él
no tenía muchas herramientas que tenemos
actualmente todo lo que él podía hacer
era depender de sus poderes de
observación y decir ok este tipo de
animales tienen pelaje o se reproducen
de esta manera o ponen huevos o no ponen
huevos o bien tienen columna vertebral o
no o qué sé yo esto era lo mejor que
podía hacer cuando hacía la taxonomía de
los organismos pero desde entonces
obviamente ha habido toneladas de
innovaciones en nuestra manera de
percibir a los animales o al mundo
natural y también han cambiado nuestras
herramientas para estudiar la taxonomía
entonces una cosa que él no conocía es
la evolución la bowl
con esta idea de un ancestro en común y
nuestro entendimiento de la evolución y
nuestra habilidad para ver el registro
fósil nos ayuda a tener una idea más
precisa de qué animales están
relacionados entre sí es decir podemos
ver si tienen un ancestro común reciente
o más antiguo y lo que inclusive carlos
darwin no tenía y que ahora nosotros
tenemos y usamos como una herramienta en
la taxonomía es la evidencia genética el
adn porque ahora no tenemos que depender
del registro fósil podemos ver que tan
similar es el adn de dos especies que
existen actualmente y esto nos dice hace
cuántos se separaron o bien cuando esas
dos especies se convirtieron en dos
especies distintas
ahora con lo que he dicho quiero ser muy
claro y es que esto se me hizo muy
confuso cuando vi por primera vez esta
idea de taxonomía la taxonomía es tanto
un arte como una ciencia e inclusive en
estos días las personas debaten sobre
cuál será la mejor manera de clasificar
a los organismos hasta el día de hoy el
adn ha sido nuestra mejor herramienta
nos da una manera más sistemática y más
analítica para decidir qué tan cercanos
son dos animales pero en gran medida
muchas de estas categorías son
arbitrarias es decir donde haces la
distinción entre reino filo clase orden
familia tribu o género es un poco
arbitrario estas solo son escogidas con
base en lo que dijeron los primeros
taxonomistas incluyendo a carlos linneo
y diciendo oh esto se ve como un
organismo que deberíamos agrupar por
aquí pero realmente ellos pudieron
agruparlos en un nivel superior o
inferior entonces estas cosas que
tenemos aquí
manera son arbitrarias y un modo más
analítico es solo ver qué tanto adn
tienen en común y luego usar eso como
una medida para ver qué tan separados
están dos animales entre sí o bueno
espera realmente debería decir dos
especies porque la taxonomía no sólo es
válida para los animales aplica para
plantas bacterias y arqueas y todo tipo
de cosas entonces la taxonomía es una
cosa más amplia que solo para los
animales ahora una vez que ya hablé de
todo esto pensé que sería divertido para
entender mejor cómo funciona la
taxonomía moderna que comenzó con carlos
linneo usar este árbol que tengo aquí
para darnos cuenta de donde estamos los
humanos donde figuramos en esta gran
imagen y obviamente solo estoy dibujando
una pequeña fracción o debería decir muy
pequeña fracción del universo de
organismos que hasta ahora conocemos
pero al menos enmarca la imagen de lo
que nosotros entendemos por taxonomía y
en particular de lo que entendemos por
no
los mismos por lo que entendemos de los
humanos a nuestra especie
nosotros mismos nos llamamos humanos
pero realmente somos los homo sapiens
sapiens es el nombre de la especie y
homo es el nombre del género y todo lo
que puede hacer aquí es decir lo
siguiente sí o no es el género entonces
que otras especies hay dentro de ese
género como la realidad es al menos
hasta donde sabemos que no hay otras
especies vidas dentro del género como
probablemente nosotros matamos a todos
oa lo mejor de alguna manera nos
cruzamos con ellos lo cual argumentaría
que no éramos especies distintas pero lo
más probable es que estas especies
estuvieran compitiendo en el mismo
ecosistema y rápidamente se volvieron
especies en peligro de extinción cuando
compitieron con nuestros antepasados uno
de los organismos más recientes dentro
de este género son los neandertales y el
té no formal de la especie para ellos
es de under silence is sin embargo
existe un debate si ellos son una
especie distinta a la nuestra o no ahora
bien si vamos más arriba en el árbol de
la vida nos vamos a encontrar con la
triple este es un nivel superior en las
categorías taxonómicas y a lo mejor las
escuchado o tal vez no pero la tribu
viene de que nosotros los humanos
tendemos a ser un poco más meticulosos
en la clasificación entre más cercanas
sean a la especie humana cuanto más nos
alejamos en el árbol de la vida tendemos
a ser menos meticulosos o tal vez no
pero lo que quiero decirte es que cuando
vamos a un nivel superior llegamos a la
tribu y nuestra tribu es la medida y
estoy seguro que no lo estoy
pronunciando bien pero lo importante
aquí es que hay otros géneros en esta
tribu o meaning que no pertenecen al
género homo y definitivamente no estoy
enlistando a todas por aquí debe de
haber más y más y más y es por eso que
puse todas estas ramas aquí
el ejemplo que se me ocurrió ponerte es
el del chimpancé común este de aquí
el chimpancé común tiene como género pan
y como especie de trogloditas entonces
para referirnos a ellos en un nombre
formal el chimpancé común es el pan
trogloditas y esta es otra convención
que puso cardos dineo esta convención
dice que para referirte a una especie en
particular dice es tanto el género de la
especie y ojo la primera letra del
género va en mayúscula y el término de
la especie se escribe en minúsculas
entonces nosotros somos los homo sapiens
estos de aquí serían los homo
neanderthalensis y este sería el pan
troglodytes o mejor conocido como
chimpancé común ahora qué te parece si
vamos a un nivel superior y en un nivel
superior llegamos a la familia y
nosotros estamos en la familia
y estoy seguro que lo estoy pronunciando
mal pero esto no sirve para decirte que
todo lo que estoy enlistando ahorita
pertenece a la misma familia y solo para
dar un ejemplo y para que conozcas un
animal que no está en la tribu o minnie
lee pero está en la familia hominidae
puedes fijarte en el gorila en el gorila
cuyo nombre formal es gorilla gorilla o
gorila y este es el nombre real de la
especie y su familia es la humanidad que
por cierto también muchas veces a esta
familia se le conoce como la familia de
los grandes simios de los grandes
ahora vamos a movernos a un nivel
superior y la razón por la que estoy
haciendo todo esto y la razón por la
cual no estoy siendo exhaustivo con las
demás especies que están en nuestra
tribu o lo demás es que solo estoy
haciendo una imagen de la clasificación
conforme nos alejamos de nuestra tribu
nuestra familia o ahora nuestro orden
vamos a llegar a cosas que van más atrás
en el tiempo donde las similitudes
genéticas entre nuestros antepasados y
los humanos se vuelven más y más
distintas e incluso si vemos de una
manera superficial solo las diferencias
físicas éstas se van a volver más y más
notorias entonces cuando vas a una
categoría superior esta vez vamos a
llegar al orden y nosotros estamos en el
orden de los primates y estoy seguro que
esta es una palabra que has escuchado en
algún momento el término primate se
refiere a estos animales que bueno en su
mayoría viven en los árboles en selvas o
en su dado caso que son descendientes de
cosas que vivieron en
y que con sus extremidades pueden
sujetar cosas y en términos generales
son buenos escalando aunque bueno no
todos
de hecho los humanos probablemente son
los peores o uno de los peores primates
en cuanto a escalar se trata pero bueno
esto en general es lo que pensamos
cuando hablamos de un primate y cuando
tienes pensar en un primate que no sea
un gran simio puedes pensar en los
babuinos estos que tenemos aquí este es
un primate pero no es un gran simio
algunos babuinos no viven en los árboles
otros tal vez sí pero probablemente
todos ellos son descendientes de cosas
que vivían los árboles y es por eso que
sus manos y sus pies se ven de esa forma
ahora vayamos a un nivel superior y si
subimos un poco más en esta
clasificación vamos a llegar justo a la
clase y nuestra clase es amalia es decir
los mamíferos estamos hablando de los
mamíferos y estoy seguro que tú has
escuchado mucho de ellos
los mamíferos son animales que respiran
oxígeno tienden a tener un pelaje o un
cabello le dan leche a sus crías tienen
glándulas mamarias activas y hay otras
cosas de las que podemos hablar las
cuales caracterizan a los mamíferos pero
no me voy a ir a una definición rigurosa
solo estoy dando ejemplos de las
características de los mamíferos aunque
bueno no sean primates y justo ahora te
voy a mostrar a un oso polar este que
tengo aquí el cual es un mamífero pero
no es un primate y también podría
mostrarte no sé a un tigre o una jirafa
o un caballo y muchas especies más pero
no me voy a detener y vamos a seguir
avanzando en nuestra clasificación así
que si me voy un poco más arriba voy a
llegar al filo y nuestro filón o film es
your data es decir los bordados y de
hecho también estamos en el sur filo o
el surf y lo que no escribí aquí
vértebra está lo que significa que
tenemos vértebras
y que tenemos con una vértebra y tenemos
una médula espinal en ella pero bueno
hablemos de los cortados los bordados
son un poco más generales los cortados
son un film un filo donde lo que tienen
en común es su arreglo su estructura es
decir dónde está su boca donde están sus
órganos digestivos
dónde está el ano dónde está la columna
vertebral dónde está el cerebro y dónde
están los ojos y todos están en el mismo
lugar si piensas en eso todo lo que
existe acá abajo tiene la siguiente
estructura su tipo de estructura general
es bueno tienen una columna vertebral
por aquí tienen un cerebro por aquí
tienen un par de ojos por aquí tienen
una boca y luego esta boca conduce a un
tipo de sistema digestivo
más o menos así y bueno al final de este
sistema digestivo todos tienen un ano
esta es la forma general en la que
puedes ver a un cortado y ojo no estoy
siendo muy riguroso en cómo se describe
un cortado pero si quieres pensar en un
core dado que no es el mamífero puedes
ver a este de aquí el cual es un tiburón
blanco o un gran tiburón blanco algunos
de los animales que no son mamíferos
pero son cordados son los peces o los
tiburones ahora vamos a un nivel
superior y justo quiero llegar aquí al
reino nosotros estamos en el reino
animal ya el reino de los animales y
ahora empezamos a ver cosas que no se
parecen en nada a los seres humanos el
reino animal es la categoría más amplia
que pensó carlos linneo bueno tal vez él
también se adentró en los árboles pero
hablemos un poco del reino animal cuando
piensas en el reino animal y piensas en
cosas que no son cordados bueno puedes
pensar en cosas como
o medusas o un buen de cosas más y si
todavía nos vamos a un nivel superior y
hablamos de eucar ya esto de aquí el
cual es nuestro dominio eucar ya es
decir estamos pensando en el dominio
donde están todos los organismos que
tienen células y dentro de esas células
hay estructuras complejas
entonces si estás en eucar ya tienes
células con estructuras complejas y si
estás en procariotas no tienes
estructuras complejas dentro de tu
celular
pero otros eucariontes que no son
animales bueno son cosas como las
plantas este de aquí y obviamente no le
estoy haciendo justicia a toda esta rama
del árbol de la vida que tenemos aquí la
cual puede ser más rica o es tan rica
como todo lo que hemos dibujado antes
esta es sólo una pequeña muy pequeña
fracción de un árbol de la vida completo
y si todavía quiere decir más arriba
podemos pensar aquí en
y en este nivel más grande te debes de
preguntar qué tipo de vida no es
eucariontes es decir no tenemos estas
estructuras complejas como una
mitocondria o un núcleo celular y bueno
puedes pensar en cosas como las
bacterias y si todavía quiere decir más
allá puedes pensar en cosas como dos
virus que incluso se sigue debatiendo si
son seres vivos o no lo son ya que estos
organismos que tenemos aquí dependen de
otros seres vivos para reproducirse pero
ellos si tienen material genético como
todos los demás y es que esta idea me
parece algo alucinante observa lo que
acabo de decir todos estos seres siendo
tan distintos no se mira la planta
puedes ver a las plantas de tu casa oa
los árboles que ves cuando vas camino a
tu casa o bien piensa en una bacteria o
en esta medusa que tenemos aquí todos
estos organismos tienen en común
adn todos tienen adn y este adn en
general se replica de la misma manera en
todos ellos de hecho eso está bastante
loco porque todos estamos relacionados
podemos decir que todos tenemos un
ancestro en común lo que nos lleva a la
pregunta pues qué hay de los virus bueno
aquí te dejo no sin antes quiero hacerte
saber que la taxonomía es una ciencia
que vale la pena estudiar ya que justo
así podemos entender dónde estamos en el
universo de las formas vivas pero
también quiero hacerte saber que la
taxonomía hay un poco de arte en decidir
cómo hacemos todas estas clasificaciones
es decir en donde quieres enfocarte ya
sea que te quieres enfocar en sus
características o en cómo se reproducen
o en cómo alimentar a sus crías o en
cómo se mueven o cómo respiran o cosas
así bueno esto es todo por este vídeo